[Music]
what's up wisecrack
michael here to once again try to prove
to myself
and my mom that i in fact did not waste
my 20s by studying the work of dead
philosophers while my
friends achieved financial stability and
bought homes for their burgeoning
families
so for this round we wanted to revisit a
wisecrack staple
and something you all have asked us to
cover
season 4 of rick and morty now the show
deals with an abundance of philosophical
themes but
i want to focus on one that's both very
present in season four
and one of my favorites death
so let's all channel our inner goths and
get into this philosophy reacts to rick
and morty season four
as always spoilers ahead now before we
get into it i want to take a second to
talk about wisecracks patreon
and how it can help keep you clear of
the type of all-encompassing existential
despair we'll be talking about in
today's video because
existence can be a rough hang and
sometimes it's the little things that
help keep us
going wisecrack patrons get awesome
perks like early access to ad-free
versions of all of our videos a private
discord server for wisecrack fans to
hang out and chat about everything from
memes to fast food favorites to
philosophy and
regular patron-only streams where we
chat about recent wisecrack content
upcoming videos and talk with patrons
about what they're currently reading
watching and eating and memberships
start at just two dollars
which is only eight quarters best of all
the community you'll find on the
wisecrack
patreon will keep you from complete
existential dread as you ponder the
possibility of being alone in the
universe
and if that doesn't work you can at
least keep yourself distracted by all
the extra content so go to
patreon.comwisecrack today to check it
out
now back to the show and now let's take
a look at the first
episode in which morty gets his hands on
some death crystals that allow him to
see
how and when he's going to die based on
what decisions he makes
obviously this is going to end well
let's check out the clip
do they kill you you're thinking of
bullets morty death crystals show you
how you're gonna die
[Music]
jesus christ i die a million times your
future stems from your
present which if you're living right
keeps changing
okay um now i really like this death
crystal stuff
as it gives me an excuse to talk about
one of my favorite philosophers soren
kierkegaard
for one thing dude was obsessed with
death and this obsession
worked its way into his philosophy one
of his books
is called the sickness unto death which
rather than being a study on 19th
century pandemics was about a
disease he thinks we're all infected
with from birth
despair and sadly there's no vaccine for
this one
for kierkegaard despair makes us all
walking balls of tension
caught between all the freedom and
wonder that our big brains are capable
of
and the cold necessity that we still
have to eat
and sleep and one day die because of
this
we exist in the present moment while
also being aware of all of our future
possibilities
and morty's crystals make all of this
literal
he is seduced by the possibilities of
the future
while disregarding what his actions mean
in the present
and that's even after his grandpa tries
to hit him with some wisdom
the truth is anyone that knows how
they're definitely gonna die is either
boring as hell or about to get shut down
okay um for kierkegaard this is actually
just true
what rick said anyone who knows how
they're gonna die loses what makes us
human which is our freedom
okay now kierkegaard probably wasn't
considering death crystals when he
argued that but to embrace our humanity
we have to accept
both all the awesome unknown
possibilities including that your hot
high school crush will one day sob over
your dying body
and the depressing reality that we're
all gonna die one way or another rick on
the other hand
and this is weird exhibits a relatively
healthy understanding of our relation to
death
he warns morty against being obsessed
with its inevitability
because he recognizes that the self is a
balancing act between a healthy
acceptance of
our mortality and the freedom to keep
living our lives
okay we're gonna keep going you just use
these to win fights i don't use them
people that spend their life avoiding
death are already dead
they're also rich and i like to spend my
life with their money
oh my god jessica oh i love that people
that spend their life avoiding death are
already dead okay so along with being
a great senior yearbook quote rick's
advice here
really vibes with kierkegaard's
discussion of despair
because in trying to avoid death you end
up sacrificing your freedom
which leads to a ton of despair and in
other words
when you try to avoid death you're
really avoiding
living your life and by being obsessed
with how his life is going to end
morty is gonna miss out on everything
that's potentially good about his
present you're gonna be a lot happier if
you focus on the moment rather than on
how you're gonna die
who's worried about that rick once again
is spot
on when you can't live life in the
moment your life is going to be
miserable
for kierkegaard this idea of the moment
is crucial to how we understand our
existence
because when we focus on living in the
moment we're not worrying about a future
we can't control
or getting depressed thinking about a
past that we can't redo
obviously at this point in the episode
morty still hasn't learned
anything even though for once rick is
giving advice that
isn't just cold cosmic nihilism so we're
going to jump ahead to the end
after all the death and destruction to
see what happens when our guys are
safely
back in the garage let's see what
they've learned hey
uh sorry i didn't listen to you and
tried to kill the whole world and stuff
i guess i got to learn how to live in
the moment a little more
oh boy so you actually learned something
today what is this full house
i was living in the moment all day and
it kept getting me killed by nazis i
think you have to think ahead
and live in the moment once again he's
right um he's telling
morty to think about his life both in
terms of what's going on now and
what the future might hold now to
kierkegaard the death crystals
probably would seem to enable one of our
worst tendencies to obsess
over all of the future's possibilities
rather than narrowing them down and
deciding to actually
do one thing put differently if you're
obsessed with a non-existent future
jessica
you might miss out on the real jessica
right in front of you a bunch of us
girls were gonna go skinny dipping later
if you wanted to join
no thanks i'm assuming we maybe
get together in our 40s if despair
is an obsession with infinite
possibility the way to get over this is
to narrow it down to one possibility and
then actualize it in
the moment i.e maybe you don't turn down
an opportunity to go out with your crush
just because a death crystal tells you
to avoid it so you'll die next to her 70
years from now
so it's great that morty realized this
not so great that he realized this after
basically becoming a domestic terrorist
now the exploration of death keeps going
in episode 2 of the season
where a meeting between rick and an
invading pooper
on his toilet planet forces them both to
think about what the point of our
existence
really is okay let's start on rick's
poop planet right after he suspects
someone else is using his secret toilet
reverse digestion extrapolation
time to meet your maker oh boy um now
rick gets it something
super important here every philosopher
ever has likely multiple times
uh so is there at least something
vaguely philosophical about the
necessity of defecation
all right um no no that's that's not
very philosophical at
all so let's catch up with rick after he
then goes and tracks
down his phantom pooper you uh
you dropped that i'll have to call you
back
where do you want to die life has been
hollow
since i lost her using your toilet was
nice though
i'm a bit of a shy pooper so sad
i'm ready when you are wow um and shouts
to any shy poopers currently watching
this
we see you and we respect you so tony
who is our toilet thief
he thinks he's about to die and i don't
know about you but if that were me i'd
be really freaked out
um i don't want to die yet but as a lot
of philosophers have pointed out going
all the way back to socrates
it's kind of stupid to be afraid of
death because
why would we be afraid of something
we've never experienced
right like you wouldn't say that
something tasted gross before we had a
chance to eat it
so why would you be scared of death when
you haven't died now a more appropriate
response to death and maybe the one that
tony is is really going through here
is anxiety now this happens to be a mood
explored by our dude kierkegaard
and later by german philosopher martin
heidegger who is very much not
our buddy and you can google him to find
out why but heidegger thought that the
real task of philosophy
was to think about what it means that
our lives are one-way journeys towards
the grave
now heidegger called this being towards
death
and this being towards death seems to be
what tony starts experiencing here as he
assumes
that rick is about to kill him now
heidegger thought that when we face the
fact of our deaths we get anxious
and this anxiety differs from fear
because we fear something
determinant like rick's fear of letting
tony in as an actual friend
now anxiety on the other hand doesn't
have a fixed object
it's like a full-on existential mood
like existence is pain
in me seeks parlance now for heidegger
in anxiety
we come like face to face with our true
selves
and we block out all the day-to-day bull
that distracts us from really thinking
about our existence so
anxiety turns out to be kind of a good
thing and for tony
it seems that his anxiety has shown him
that his authentic existence has a lot
to do with
pooping in privacy and being proud of it
you know what shy pooping is rick
it's a pointless bid for control you
want to take the one part of life that
you truly think is yours and you want to
protect it from a universe that takes
whatever it wants
it took my wife it clearly took
something from you
we can spend our lives fighting that but
we can choose to be free
i'm not kidding that's legitimately
beautiful when tony right there says
that we can choose to be free he's no
longer
just talking about pooping he's getting
at the relationship between how we think
about death and our own freedom
and this is something that was crucial
for heidegger who thought freedom
only really comes through acknowledging
our mortality now tony seems to take
this to heart
and from this he seems to get over his
death anxiety so that he can truly
live at least until uh let's keep going
and we'll see
tony died excuse me
he quit his job started living life to
the fullest
he crashed into a tree space skiing down
mountain space everest
mountain space space everest okay uh
jesus i i gotta process this okay um
r.i.p tony obviously but it sounds
cliche to say that
everybody dies but not everyone truly
lives
but like other famous cliches uh broken
clock can still write twice a day
a dog in the hat is better than a fish
in the toe you know the road to take if
you know the path to make
two beers before breakfast you'll ace
that math test there's truth to it now
for
heidegger we can only live an authentic
life if we confront the reality of
death and find meaning in our lives in
spite of it it's that anxiety thing we
already talked about and
tony seems to have embraced his life and
spent it doing things that held meaning
for him
like base skiing and mount space everest
without a fear of death holding him back
and i'm sure that's what rick is going
to take away from this
whole experience so let's go see what
lessons he's learned there he is there's
our guy congrats tony
enjoy using it all by yourself while you
sit there and think about how nobody
wants to be around
you and how you ruined it for yourself
because you're a huge piece of sh
look at you sitting there king [ __ ] on
his throne of loneliness
the saddest piece of garbage in the
entire cosmos
well that's that's legit very sad um it
seems like rick didn't really learn much
here or at least
um didn't get inspired by tony to start
living his life
though in fairness many of my favorite
philosophers are miserable pieces of
so maybe rick is ultimately living too
philosophically or something or maybe
i'm just idealizing toxic intellectual
father figures to deal with my own
issues
yeah let's let's wrap this up now um now
to paraphrase
the great fictional novelist eli cash we
all know that death is the worst part of
human existence but what this video
presupposes
is maybe it isn't while we might think
of
death as a limiting factor to our
experience philosophers and shy poopers
alike
have considered how our finite life
spans are what give our lives meaning in
the first place
and season four rick and morty really
makes us think about how pondering death
can actually enrich
our existence because let's be real
we're all gonna die
hopefully painlessly and in our sleep
but at least one of you is going to
choke to death in a burger king parking
lot after you try to swallow a chicken
fry hole
you know who you are and i'm sorry but
that's why you put sauce on the chicken
fry to lubricate it as it goes into your
throat
but for the rest of us death can be
something that makes us take
advantage of the time that we do have to
do as much cool [ __ ] possible or you
know poop and stuff
but what do you guys think can rick and
morty help us reflect on the surprising
joys of our finite existence or are we
just overthinking the scariest part of
life
let us know you think in the comments
and definitely let us know if there's
something else you want to see me try my
best to
do a philosophy on thanks to our patrons
for all your support
hit that subscribe button like you're
hitting the flusher after a legendary
fourth meal session and don't forget to
ring that bell
thanks for watching guys later
[Music]
you